Nathan Ruiz is the editor in chief of
the school newspaper and he joins us now
Nathan good morning thanks for joining
us what's the reaction been to your
column uh it's been mostly from people
from Central Michigan obviously they got
a hold of it through their school
newspaper push it out so it's been a lot
of it's been fairly negative
understandably I think from Central
Michigan folk part of the issue from our
perspective with that was we reached out
to Central Michigan's paper about doing
kind of a head-to-head editorial
situation where we write one day where I
want and they never got back to us I
spoke to their sports that had briefly
said he'd get back to me and he never
did in a certain point we had a paper to
put together so our plan was to just
ride the editorial and put it out
ourselves next morning turns out that
Sam life push it out there and kind of
said you know OSU OSU student papers
saying that seem you should give up the
win we disagree what you think so they
kind of just said it to the wolves in
that way so from our perspective that
was really frustrating they kind of just
threw it threw us out there to their
readership and all their only one was we
disagree but again I think I think the
editorial is partially being
misinterpreted and I think it comes down
to the use of our our use of the word
integrity yeah I think people are seeing
that and assuming me saying that are
saying that seeing you lacks integrity
which is not at all what we're saying
okay how did you get to this point
Nathan that you explain the premise of
why Central Michigan should give that
victory back I don't I'm going to say
this straight up I don't think Central
Michigan should give the victory back
the premise of the article is not
central michigan should give up the wing
it's saying Central Michigan has the
opportunity to show integrity if it were
to do so do you know if they're even
able to do this with the NC double-a did
you check with the NCAA my understanding
is that it is up to Central Michigan
that I posed you want to appeal to the
NCAA it would be irrelevant they would
have to appeal to Central Michigan and
it would then be in
michigan pants to say we're going to
give up this one which I don't have any
expectation of them to do OSU want to do
it if they were in the same situation
and so it's entirely in Central Michigan
pan to my understanding would you have
written the same column if Oklahoma
State had one on a play like this you
know I that's an interesting point Dan I
don't I don't think we would have I
think it would have been I think the
story would have been more like OS from
our perspective at least OSU escape
don't you got about Nathan it's about
integrity and see that's like an
interesting point and I think then maybe
we make the argument that like osu has a
chance to prove its integrity again like
i don't i'm not trying to bash the
people of central mystery that was not
our point in writing this editorial it
was not meant to be an attack on the
people who attend Central Michigan in
alumni of central mystery it was saying
here's an opportunity to show that
integrity and oh it's you you know
prides itself on integrity as well I
think our use of the word integrity was
potentially flawed I think it's being
misinterpreted but you know I think if
it goes the other way then we probably I
think it'd be our responsibility as an
independent student publication from
Oklahoma State University to may be
right that same editorial no yeah but
you now you set yourself up that
something happens with Oklahoma State
and something happens to their benefit
then you're probably going to have to
come to the defense of the opposing
school what's the responsibility of
Oklahoma State's coaching staff to know
the rules oh definitely definitely it's
on that too i said that i spoke with a
student radio station at Central
Michigan a couple days ago and I said
the same thing mike gundy didn't know
the rules or is unsure of the rule and
that's a huge issue i think you know
Mike Gundy has taken ownership of not
understanding the rule completely or not
knowing that he understood the rule
completely he went out there immediately
after the game instead I called the pass
plays my fault like he took ownership of
it so there is plenty of responsibility
Central Michigan to their like they were
given an extra play and they played it
that is what happened in X the refs gave
them an extra play osu did not argue it
and Central Michigan ran another plate
that is what hurt and it's not about
Central Michigan running
play it's about afterwards they have an
opportunity to say hey you know this is
a great win Thank play was amazing but
that place shin of house and so I've
zero expectation on them to do that
again editorial is not calling upon them
to do that it's just saying if they were
to do so it'd be a great example of
their integrity Nathan thanks for
joining us keep stirring it up thank you
you have a great day all right Nathan
Ruiz the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience